we have with us in the studio
mr.narayana murthi
is the founder and mentor in chief of
Infosys India's second largest software
company Infosys was founded in 1981 with
a capital of $250 and today Infosys
market capitalization is about 22
billion dollars so mr. Woodleigh welcome
thank you very much it is a great
pleasure to have you on our campus and
to answer some questions about the
developments in India
first of all Infosys has become a kurai
connick institution in India but in
course of a very short time 25 years it
has risen to the top how do you account
for this maturity cries of Infosys in
the context of India well you know
you're right we celebrate our 25th year
this year in fact on 2nd July 2006 would
have completed 25 years first of all I
must say God has been very kind to us
because as we pastors said when God is
shy to announce his presence he comes in
the form of chants having accepted that
let me say this right from day one when
we founded the company when we sat for 4
hours to discuss what we should seek in
this journey we were all unanimous that
we would seek respect we would seek
respect from customers from our
employees from our investors from our
vendor partners from the government of
the land and from the society and we
said if we seek respect from each of
these stakeholders we will do the right
thing by their
and if we did the right thing by them
then everything will fall into place so
I'm happy that the company has not
swerved from that path of seeking
respect right from day one as of now and
that perhaps is one of the reasons why
you know we have had whatever little
success we have had so far
but within 1981 India was not at all
friendly towards enterprise the kind of
stuff you set up from what I recall you
had difficulty getting your first
computer getting your first telephone
line and how do you overcome those
obstacles well in entrepreneurship is
all about courage it is about thinking
of a powerful idea and then converting
it into wealth when we founded the
company in 1981 we had tremendous
friction to business but there were two
important paradigm changes that were
taking place at that time first was of
course the PC revolution micro software
started in 1976 many computers and super
mini computers had come into existence
Borland was about to announce the first
sub hundred dollar software in other
words we realized that the power of
software would be unleashed in the years
to come and number two that software
would become more and more demanded
because the costs were going down and
people were realizing the power of
software that was the first paradigm the
second is the paradigm of globalization
i define globalization as sourcing
capital from where it is cheapest
sourcing talent from where it is best
available producing where it is most
cost-effective and selling where the
markets are without being
trained by national boundaries now this
we realized was a unique opportunity for
countries like India to leverage the
power of the availability of
english-speaking technical talent to
produce powerful software for the global
market and thanks to these two paradigms
I think emphasis took off though the
first ten years we had tremendous
friction to business and thanks to the
economic reforms of 1991 emphasis took
off from 1990 to just give you a data
point between 1981 and 1992 we agree our
revenues from 130,000 dollars in 1991
eight 1980 1981-82 to about 1.6 million
dollars in 1992 but within 1992 and 2006
we went from one point six million
dollars to two point one five billion
dollars in other words we grew by a
factor of approximately about 1300 times
in the neck in the second half that is
approximately about 1213 years
as against 10 times in the first ten
years in fact you mentioned the 91 try
reform 91 crisis in March 2001 India was
left with a total foreign reserve of 1.2
billion dollars which worth 2 weeks our
import yes and that's exactly the amount
I think you are worth of today yourself
according to Forbes magazine so it shows
the kind of the journey you have made in
this 25 years now the question is apart
from the availability of Indian
technical talent and apart from the
existence of market you needed something
to link the market to the Indian
technical talent and from
what I recall you initially took your
engineers to the client site as what is
called as Bob body shopping and that
kind of model changed with the arrival
of satellite and then fiber optic is
right whether you're right because in
the beginning we had no access to data
communication lines it took us a year to
get a telephone line it would take us
two years and about 25 visits to Delhi
to get a license to import a computer
worth $50,000 in other words everything
was stacked against us so we realized
that if we want to have a going business
then it is best if the talented teams
for emphasis when actually to customer
officers produce the software there for
them installed it and supported them
rather than doing it from India but you
know I must say that all of that changed
in a dramatic manner with the economic
reforms of 1991 because dr. Manmohan
Singh did know at that time he was the
finance minister now the prime minister
he did a few things it is remarkable one
he removed licensing which meant that we
need we did not have to go to Delhi and
wait in the corridors to import anything
today government is not the bottleneck
it's just that we had finalized what we
want to buy and we buy it quickly second
he introduced current account
convertibility till 1991 we couldn't set
up offices abroad we couldn't travel
easily you know we couldn't hire
consultants in quality brand equity etc
from abroad etc all of that got changed
when he introduced current account
convertibility third he abolished the
office of the controller of capital
issues this is an officer who determined
at what price we would have our IPO and
this officer had no idea of capital
markets
and he would rarely allow you to list
your stock at anything better than your
for value which meant there was very
little incentive for entrepreneurs to
list because then you would give away so
much of equity and raise so little funds
on the other hand when dr. Manmohan
Singh said look you can decide the price
at which you will have your IPO in
consultation with your investment
bankers then all of us realize that we
would get the fair price from the market
market was going to be the determinant
and that was another important thing he
did do to encourage entrepreneurship and
finally he a load 100% equity for
multinationals now IBM and coca-cola had
walked out of India in 1990s 1977 and
when he allowed these companies to have
100% equity then what happened was we
had tremendous competition in India not
so much of the market because market
hardly existed but for talent and
because there was tremendous competition
for talent in India and these
multinationals had it had great name
great prestige a lot of money etc we had
to fight for talent in competition with
these great multinationals and that
exactly what is what made indeed
companies stronger because that's when
we realized that we have to create good
infrastructure we're to give good
salaries you know we're to give good
work environment if we want to attract
good people I would say these are the
four things that I did now in since in
India has now become kind of leader of
outsourcing in the world but what are
the challenges if see India faces in
maintaining its leadership well there
are many many challenges first we have
to move up the value chain which means
we have to enhance our per capita
revenue productivity I always say that
just as the per capita GDP is a good
index of the development of a nation per
capita and a Productivity is a good
index of the growth of a corporation so
we have to enhance or for capital you
know productivity to do that we have to
become more and more relevant or customs
business and we have to have greater and
greater impact on that which means we
have to learn to provide more and more
end-to-end business solutions Newbridge
in technology that is what in other
words way to do more of consulting
weight or more of systems integration
etc second we have to handle scalability
scalability in terms of number of
customers scalability in terms of number
employees scalability in terms of
physical infrastructure technological
infrastructure etcetera etcetera for
example today we have about 52,000
employees we have about 55,000 node
networks you know we have to dream about
20,000 people in a year
you know everywhere you know we have
recruited 300 student 300 people from
the colleges in the u.s. now we are
taking them to my so for a nine-month
long training program they're the first
time in history of India that a set of
300 employees will work in the United
States or going to India for a training
of nine months so these are all these
scalability is another challenge third I
think ability to work in multicultural
teams is another important challenge
fourth I would say that we need to
create better infrastructure in in the
cities because that's where all our
operations are fifth I would say we're
to enhance our brand equity because we
have to get to more and more you know
hundreds of millions of dollars a
project more and more maybe billion
dollars of outsourcing projects etc etc
because so far India's a poor in Infosys
kind of is somewhat apart but lot of
other IT enabled companies are using
basically cheap labor educated cheap
labor to leverage in the
is that something sustainable you know I
I have a slightly different view on that
at the end of the day business is all
about bringing better value for money as
economists say price is what you pay
value is what you get right so if for a
dollar we can give our customers better
value for money one way of looking at it
is better value for money
another way of looking at is cheaper so
beat as long as we are able to satisfy
our customer needs better and better and
better it doesn't matter so I I don't
look at it as providing things cheap I
look at it as partying better value for
money yeah no I think what I meant was
that that cheap level would increasing
the other countries will be able to
offer as well so no I think India has
some unique advantages you know we are a
nation of billion people we produce
anywhere from 3.5 to 4 million graduates
every year you know we use 450 thousand
engineers we produce about three hundred
thousand masters in computer
applications graduates and all of that
is is getting enhanced year after year
after year and at the end of the day
let's remember if we have to solve the
problem of poverty in India the only way
we can do is by creating more and more
jobs and if you can if you want to
create more and more jobs with good
disposable income then you need to
expand in in sectors like this so but
there again I think the population of
India vast majority are in the villages
sure and so the and education is still
very poor in fact it is still over 40
percent
illiterate so so what what do you see
look at looking beyond your own IT
domain for India as a whole what do you
think should be endear strategy oh well
you know I believe that we have to do
more of many things
we have to expand the software industry
because there is considerable
opportunity in the global market second
we have to focus on low tech
manufacturing because that is how you
can create large number of jobs for the
masses of Indian who or semi-literate or
in some cases illiterate so we have to
focus on low tech manufacturing too and
create perhaps anywhere from 10 to 15
million jobs a year for the next ten
years and that cannot be done by the
software industry alone it has to be
done per force by focusing on low tech
manufacturing you have your company has
moved to China they are what's what
what's happening with China what are you
doing there well you know if you want to
be a high aspiration corporation today
if you want to be in the top five in any
sector of the economy for example in the
software services we are in the top five
in the world you have to have a presence
in China for multiple reasons one China
is a fast flowing market its GDP is
growing at 10% or so there are lots of
things happening out there so we have to
have presence a second like India China
to has a large population there is good
technical talent out there and as we
keep growing in revenues we have to
leverage the talent in China third there
is a large Chinese diaspora in Southeast
Asia and East Asia etc and Japan you
know is very near Dalian in China so you
can service Japanese clients from
northern part of China so looking at all
these things I think China is an
important piece in the jigsaw puzzle
the rapid growth of outsourcing is very
good news for country like India or
China but one sees an increasing concern
in Europe and the United States of
white-collar job leaving the country and
going outside do you see this could be a
drag on your business well you know my
view is that people in glass houses
should not throw stones at others after
all what we are doing is what we were
preached to by the West nations my
European friends my American friends
told me up 10 times in 80s how India
should become more and more open how
India should open up its borders how
India should reduce its Terra is how it
should allow computation from
multinationals etc I I agreed with all
of them and all that we are doing is we
are implementing the ideas that they
have been profoundly so at this point in
time just because shoe pinches a little
bit I don't think we should go back on
those principles so my view is at the
end of the day we are making
corporations in the u.s. in Europe in
Japan in other countries more
competitive not just for selling in
their own countries but even in third
countries so just as we accepted you
know liberalisation economic reforms
just as we open up our borders I believe
that that Western nations too would gain
from such open access globalization has
been a very become a very contested
world a lot of people are turning
anti-globalization in India it seems to
me that India is one of the most Pro
globalization country the right I would
think so because
remember that we have a coalition
government which is supported by
communist now in spite of that our
government has made many many moves
forward you know we increased foreign
holding in the banking sector to 74
percent you know we are we introduced
foreign participation in the retail
sector you know we have liberalized in
the civil aviation sector so in many
many areas we have brought in
liberalization so when you do it in the
context of a coalition government
supported from the Communist I think
it's not it's not a bad record and if
and finally the the outsourcing which
started as essentially software services
or back office work being sent outside
of Western or of an America is now
becoming a global model I think recently
an article in the Foreign Affairs by
former CEO IBM he talks about even C's
being replaced by a new model of
companies called
which he calls global integrated
enterprises and is this a trend that you
see from your perspective going to touch
other sectors of Industry you-know-who
absolutely absolutely for example at
emphasis itself you know we have a
program for infill us emphasis phase two
and what we are trying to do is to Pao
is to bring the power of globalization
the global delivery model into areas
outside of just software consulting for
example systems integration equity
research you know our customer service
in all these areas we are bringing the
power of globalization
we are leveraging the strength of talent
in India now for example another friend
of mine is is starting an enterprise to
maintain aircrafts he feels that India
would be the right place to maintain
aircraft because that people would get
best value for money
an aircraft from all over you know Asia
and perhaps some parts of Europe and at
some state from the US - could be
maintained you know from India or from
some other part of the world - but but
focused you know from the talent
available from India that reminds me
that one of the things that Infosys I
think is done is not just write codes
but for business purposes but many
industrial other operations they are
coming to you for solutions to their
problem right here sure so you are your
employees include not just code writers
but people experts from different fields
wait wait because no if we want to
become more and more relevant to
customers business if we want to have
greater and greater impact in the areas
of business relevance then we have to be
domain experts we have to understand the
business of the customer so our focus
has been to enhance the market readiness
of all people in the domain knowledge in
fact we have we have several initiatives
in this area we encourage our people to
get certified by industry associations
you know I mean you know at different
levels for example we have retail 101
retail 201 we take 300 on banking 101
etc etc with the result our people over
a period of time will become more and
more business domain knowledge
ready so it is more and more of a
consulting company just absolutely and
just a software provider
well estimate - thank you so much for
your time thank you very much